the one conversation that obliviate
than any other in my life was with a
woman who told me how a few days earlier
she drove her Jeep Wrangler to the edge
of the Grand Canyon and sat there
revving the engine thinking about
driving over even though I had severe
social anxiety in that conversation I
was totally at ease she told me what was
going on in her life in the days and
months leading up what her thoughts were
at that exact moment why she wanted to
die and why she didn't do it
we nodded and half smiled and then it
was my turn to talk about my journey to
a dining table in the hygienic community
area of the mental health wing of a
mountain town hospital I took too many
sleeping pills and after they treated me
for that they were like hey we would
love it if you would be our guest in the
psych ward we joked that her suicide
would have made a way better post card
we talked shop she allowed me to be
deeply depressed and have a genuine
connection to another person
simultaneously for the first time I
identified as somebody living with
depression and I felt good about it
like I wasn't a bad person for it now
imagine one of the people at that table
was a member of your family or a close
friend would you be comfortable talking
to them what if instead of the hospital
they were at your kitchen table and told
you they were really depressed the World
Health Organization says that depression
is the leading cause of ill health and
disability worldwide affecting 350
million people the National Institute of
Mental Health reports seven percent of
Americans experiencing depression in a
year
so depression is super common yet in my
experience most folks don't want to talk
to depressed people unless we pretend to
be happy
a cheerful facade is appropriate for
casual interactions a depressed person
can ask for extra syrup and there's
pumpkin spice latte without explaining
that they need it because they're
trapped in the infinite darkness of
their soul and they've lost all hope of
escape again depression doesn't diminish
a person's desire to connect with other
people just their ability so in spite of
what you might think talking to friends
and family living with depression can be
really easy and maybe even fun not like
Facebook selfie with Lady Gaga at an
underground party fun I'm talking about
the kind of fun where people enjoy each
other's company effortlessly nobody
feels awkward and no one accuses the sad
person of ruining the holidays why does
this chasm even exist right on the one
side you have people living with
depression who may act in off-putting or
confusing ways because they're fighting
a war in their head that nobody else can
see on the other side the vast majority
of people look across the chasm and
shake their heads like why you gotta be
so depressed you may recognize a divide
like this in your life do you want to
build a bridge across it you may not
want to build a bridge and that's a
totally valid choice or maybe you'd like
to build a stronger connection but you
have a lot of questions and concerns
your what I might call bridge curious
[Laughter]
here are some possible reasons why some
of you may avoid depressed people you
might be afraid that if you talk to
somebody while they're depressed you're
suddenly responsible for their
well-being you're not expected to be dr.
Phil just be friendly more like Ellen
[Laughter]
you may worry that you won't know what
to say and every attempt at conversation
will be awkward and you know the only
time you'll feel comfortable is when you
both just give up on talking and stare
at your phones words are not the most
important thing to focus on
you might fear seeing your shadow
hey if you have been successfully
outrunning your personal emotional
demons that's awesome may the wind be at
your back you can be the least whoo-whoo
person in the world and still connect
with depressed people maybe you've heard
that depression is contagious and you're
afraid of catching it bring some hand
sanitizer you're much more likely to
catch the joy of human bonding maybe you
see depress people differently you think
of them as flawed or defective multiple
university studies have shown that a
students are more likely to have bipolar
condition our brains aren't broken or
damaged they just work differently I
spent a lot of years thinking happy
people just don't get it I did
eventually stop discriminating against
happy people
I began battling depression when I was 8
and decades later
to my surprise I started winning I
shifted from being miserable much of the
time to enjoying life I live pretty well
with my bipolar condition and have
overcome some other mental health
conditions like overeating addiction and
social anxiety so I live on both sides
of this chasm and I'm offering some
guidance based on my experience to help
you build a bridge across it if you want
to okay it's not hard science but I
worked with a lot of people I know
who've lived with depression to refine
these suggestions okay first up some
things you might want to avoid some
don'ts one of the most off-putting
things you can say is just get over it
great idea love it it's just we already
thought of that the absence of the
ability to just get over it is
depression
[Applause]
we feel it in our bodies it's a it's a
we feel it in our bodies it's a physical
thing for us so and medically it's no
different from telling someone with a
broken ankle or cancer to just get over
it mm-hmm
don't be hell-bent on fixing us like
thank you but the pressure can make us
depressed people feel like we're
disappointing you also things that make
some people feel better may not work for
us you can't cure clinical depression by
getting ice cream which is unfortunate
because that would be live in the dream
don't let or don't take a negative
response personally so I have a friend
who about a year ago message me they it
was really isolated and depressed and I
suggested some things for him to do and
he was like no no and no and I got mad
like how dare he not embraced my
brilliant wisdom and then I remembered
times I've been depressed and how I
thought I was doomed in all possible
futures or everybody suddenly hated me
and things like that it didn't matter
how many people told me otherwise I
didn't believe them so I let my friend
know I cared and I didn't take it
personally don't let a lack of bubbly
happiness freak you out hey it's not a
shark attack call the pens bar my friend
is sad we can be sad and okay at the
same time I'm gonna say that again
because in our society we're taught the
opposite and so it's counterintuitive
people can be sad and okay at the same
time so some of these things may apply
to you personally some may not take
what's useful
and remember you don't have to connect
if you want to here are some suggestions
that may help some dues talk to us in
your natural voice right yeah you don't
need to put on a sad voice because we're
depressed you don't sneeze when you're
talking to somebody with a cold it's not
rude
to be upbeat you can be you okay
if you make an offer to be there for us
clearly state what you can and can't do
I have told people hey call or text
anytime but I might not be able to get
back to you that same day it's totally
cool to not make an offer or to make an
arrow offer with really clear boundaries
around it give us a sense of control I
have like get our consent I have a
friend who a while back when I was
having a depressive episode reached out
and said hey I want to check in with you
can I call you every day maybe text you
every day and call later in the week
what works for you by getting my
permission she earned my complete
confidence and remains you know one of
my best friends today and my last
suggestion is interact about not
depression aka normal stuff I have a
friend who when people were worried
about him they would call and ask if he
wanted to go shopping or help them clean
out their garage your depressed friends
could be a good source of free labor
[Laughter]
what I'm really getting at is invite
them to contribute to your life in some
way
even if it's as small as asking you to
go see a movie that you wanted to see in
the theatre so that's a lot of do's and
don'ts and maybes and it's not by any
means a definitive list the thing to
remember is that they're all grounded in
one guiding principle it's what allowed
the woman in the Jeep Wrangler to start
me on the path to recovery without even
trying she talked to me like I belonged
and contributed exactly as I was at that
moment if you talk to a depressed person
as if their life is just as valuable
intense and beautiful as yours then
there's no need to build a bridge
between you because you've closed the
chasm focus on that instead of your
words and it may be the most uplifting
conversation of their life what could
that do for somebody you care about what
could it do for you thank you